I remember what you did
they remember too
You were the reason that we were all there
it happened because of you
and you can't tell anyone
Why would you?
It is your fault
Hi, okay. All right, then
All of it
Hello, everyone. My name is Markiplier and welcome to five nights at Candy's three now
I'm meant to get to this sooner, but I got trapped in Boston due to the blizzard
I know I said that many times, but I wasn't able to get to this game until I returned
How are you feeling today?
I'm pretty good
It's been two weeks
I understand that it was a very traumatic experience
But luckily your brother wasn't seriously hurt
You have to remember they weren't real
they were just machines
They aren't capable of harming anyone
What happened was just an accident
He was just
Broken
Who my brother or the machine?
But it's okay now. You're safe here
You remembered them from the theater?
Ah yes,
the old one that you and your father went to a year ago, right?
Your father has told me about what happened while you were there
You got separated from each other that day
when the incident happened
Have you still had nightmares since we last met?
Were they about those monsters you drew for me?
*Mark grunts in disgust*
You're a very creative girl
Thank you
But you can't let your fears take control of your imagination
In order for your nightmares to end you have to face your fears
I don't know if I want to do that
You have to face the monsters
Again! Don't think that's a good idea
Show them that you're not afraid
How do I do that when I'm peeing my pants in front of them?
Do you understand?
No not at all
It's the only way
*ominous silence*
Now,
Mary.
I need you to try and remember what happened on that day,
a year ago
Ok I'll try real hard. Whoever you are.
I don't know who I'm talking to but-
Oooohhhhhh *nervous laughter*
Ohhh
Ah good. I'm a creative little girl that has no eyeballs
That's... wonderful
Hello
Whoa, hey!
Aren't you even gonna say hello?
Ah, are you the-
Are you the cat thing?
Hello!
It's me!
I'm the origami cat.
How am I here? You're dreaming right now!
Mmm. Sort of, at least
This room you're in is your old room!
From before you moved!
Right now it looks like you barely remember it
You've had a lot of nightmares lately, right?
Well, that's why I'm here!
I have a couple of tricks to fighting the monsters
Remember a few years ago?
You had trouble sleeping almost every night.
No, why does everyone want me to remember my past?!
I don't get it!
So your dad gave you a cassette tape player
With a tape with quiet music that he made for you so you could sleep.
I bet it would also help you with sleeping better now
The other thing is
The monsters hate light.
So I suggest flashing light in their eyes whenever you can
Oh yeah that's good
Let me just wave my flashlight in their face
UNLESS they're under your bed
Listen for if they go there.
In such a case
Peek under the bed to see which side they're at
then go back up
and face the opposite direction
Turning your back will lure them out from under the bed
listen closely to the sound of them peeking out
and then
ha BOOOO!!!
Face back towards the opposite end of the room again
To give them a good dose of light in the eyes
Now
Go look for the tape player
I'll stay here if you need my help
Once again, you told me I was in dream
What would go getting a tape player in my dream do for me Mr. Catman?
How is that gonna make me any better at fighting the monsters?
The tape player should be somewhere up ahead
You should try and go and look for it
I wanna go to bed!
No, no! You won't stand a chance against the monsters
Please
You should go search for the tape player
It will definitely help you
Alright fine, Kitty!
Made of paper cause you're origami!
I'm gonna go do this
Ohhh, where am I goin- oh
This is the Deepscape
This is where your deepest memories are, I'm talking to you from the dreamscape
See those glowing particle thingies? They make up a path
Tape player should be somewhere ahead. Just remember to stay on the path, so the Shadows can't get you, if you get lost
I can get you back only if you're on the path, I can't reach you if you're out in the darkness
Let me know
if you need to get back by pressing R
You mean this darkness?
Oooookay
Well that didn't work out for me. I just wanted to test the theory of the darkness
This is a lot different than I expected it to be and I like it. beware of the shadows stay on the path
Alrighty then I'll beware of the shadows
Okay here we go. Maybe I shouldn't run that seems to be making noise
Doo-Doo-doo Lulu
Doo-doo- oh hello. There's nothing on the back. Oh, okay, all right
Stupid me, checking the back of it. the path does not necessarily lead to every destination
Good to know at this dead-end that I'm at, ooh
I love the sea of darkness surrounding me, reminds me of the darkest uh- dark darkness in my own soul
that's a good way of saying things, what is that? whoa, hey slow down there. It's you my old friend
I thought that you had forgotten about me. It's been kind of boring in here
There isn't much room for racing around in the toy box
I remember back when we used to have a race every day. That was lots of fun. We should totally do that again sometime
Oh well
I bet you didn't come all the way down here for me
You should get what you came for and then hurry back to safety. If you have anything to say, say it now
I don't know. You have anything to say say now
I got nothing to say to you. YOU STAY DOWN IN THAT TOY BOX, WHERE I PUT YA!! YOU DONT TALK TO ME!
You didn't win me no races. Aww, I feel bad though. I shouldn't yell at my old toys, my old toys are good to me
Hello a part of a newspaper article read it? Sure after closing so soon the brand new wire animatronics were sent back to.
[@&^#^*PROPERTY OF CANDY'S BURGERS AND FRIES@^#^*]
Rumors are circulating that the animatronics will be used as a base for newer designs of advanced Fully mobile
Animatronics which are speculated to be used for a future project?
We talking about Five Nights at Freddy's? IS THAT WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT? We might be talking about that
I really like this though. It was like
I just expected it to be like the demo over and over again
But this is this is like original and interesting
Do not be afraid of stepping slightly off the path step too far away from the path however
And that is when you should be afraid
Alrighty then. DOODLY (duly) NOTED
Also, why is this path so wet? I mean I I don't appreciate it raining inside of my own head because again
This is my dream
You think I'd be able to control it. A part of a newspaper article read it? after closing so soon the brand new wire
animatronics were sent back to *[PROPERTY OF CANDY'S BURGERS AND FRIES]*
Okay, this is the same one as before
Advanced Fully mobile animatronics, which are speculated to be used for a future project. That's the exact same thing
Why do they have the same thing twice?
Peculiar unless there was some specific reason for that, but I can't understand what it would be oh well
best to just keep sprinting off into the darkness
Hello
Is this it? Found arcade game number one. Found the tape player. Good. Now I can hurry back
I think I suppose and hopefully death will not wait for me when I'm coming home
Hopefully the origami cat isn't there to actually kill me. Even though the origami cat seemed to be giving me some good advice
about how to survive this endeavor. I mean obviously he was giving me advice about the specific scenario of
the bedroom which I think is where the majority of this game is going to take place, but I do appreciate the
backstory like it's interesting to know that there's something to this character and something that tied together all the other games because to be perfectly
Frank I don't remember a lot of story out of the other games all I remember is that they were a pretty good
Five Nights At Freddy's
clone, but this is more. It's
trying to be more. That's what I can appreciate great you found
Do you remember how to use the tape player? YES YOU PUSH DEH PLAHY BUTTOHN
Super Duper! Good luck with the nightmares
Okay, thank you
Wow that seems a little passive-aggressive
Okay, all right. could you punch me in the face before I go to bed? That'll make me "feel" better all right?
Let's snooze it up
About my race cars. Oh
Here we go, then. I if I remember the demo correctly this is going to be a time. Oh
I'm ready. I'm so ready
But it's so interesting because remember to use a tape player the time goes twice as fast when it plays
It's just really interesting because it means
It means that like there's some honest-to-goodness backstory. It's me! Oh back when I had red hair in a pink mustache
All right, if I remember correctly I have to be pretty active. Oh hey! Were those always there?
Hello! Hi Sam, how ya doin'?
I don't remember if those were always there.
okay, but I don't think I'll have to be too quick on the first night the only thing that I'm expecting though is it maybe
There's going to be more animatronics lurking for me in the darkness. Hello!
How are you? Good?
Great
Boop my nose
Can I boop my adorable nose no can I boop anything's nose?  You got a boopable nose? Anybody got a boopable nose over here?
Yeah, okay, rewind. Please be kind rewind
Okay, hello
Boop your nose your nose? Ah...I don't like that HEY!
Where'd you come from oh? Yeah, you think you're gonna get away from me this time
I'v- I've learned a thing or two about where your face is and how to shine on it
Call me the shining because because I'm about to-
ah fuc(*noises)
(*Mark grumbling*)
Let me just see here- Ah!
Ok
Alright then Let's just
(*silence*)
(*Mark looks over*)
LA-D-D-D-D-D
DA-DA-DA
Okay, I remember how to do this and seems like it's gone for now
And it seems like this is going to be just as painful as it was before
Alright sooth me to sleep with your sweet lies
send me off to Lala land knowing that I'm not going to be horribly mauled by a giant Rodent
Also, this is a really clever animatronic, and how the hell did you get in my closet-et-et?
I don't like any of this.
I think is a bad adventure for me a little girl to experience
Also, am I. . is this like current time? Am I talking to that therapist person now?
Or am I (uh) just kind of reliving some horrible memories of me having too many closets?
Oh God is this symbolic or something? I don't wanna know!
Oh shit, was that something? I could have sworn I saw something creeping out of the corner of that doorway,
But now I'm not a hundred percent too sure about that. That's. . that's no good all right. I move twice Fas-okay
Hey, how's it going?
'Cause in the other five nights at Candy's games there were other animatronics on. I think these might have been the ones
Yeesh.
My God, when do these kids get any sleep!? Do they ever sleep?
I mean with five nights at Freddy's 4 it was an acceptable medium that maybe it was all a lie
And you were in a hospital because your frontal lobe had been bitten off
And you're only stuck in a perpetual world of nightmares until you would hope to either wake up or die
That was legitimately the story of five nights at Freddy's 4 did you guys know that? That is quite literally the story.
There's a lot of clues spread around in five nights at Freddy's 4
*Dramatic Bwom* Hey! hey, no don't! :3
You want something? Nope, noo?
Yeah, you're so fff-
Really wonder if there's a way to win this because in all my time playing this and the demo i-
Goddammit I've never actually had the chance to do that!
*Ethereal Echo*  Woahkay! Alright then. . .
da-da-da-DAAAAAAAA
AAAAAAAA
Oh no you're shy. . .
Yeah, I really don't know if there's a way to actually win that because holy shit. I..like
It Just doesn't make a whole lot of sense
Yee. All right, but I got to keep scanning a lot faster because apparently
He's really douchey and if this is the first night then what the hell is in store for me later?
Cuz goddamn this death surrounding me at every corner! And by death, I mean just one giant mouse!
Holy shit
okay, but yeah anyway so five nights at Freddy's 4 that was the story of a kid like it was obviously told in all of
the.. th-the Cutscenes. The old uh.. The 8-bit cutscenes
The kid was being tormented by his brother in a facility where he thought death and destruction was all around him and
And I'm not a hundred percent sure but they they alluded to this dream
Theory like I believe that Scott had like this continuous theorem between all of the different games that
Suggested they all spawned from the mind of a child those are may not be the exact words
But they're pretty close and so in this along the same veins the therapist talking about how
the kid
Shouldn't let her fears
conquer her imagination are these things real are they really here stalking a little girl in her bedroom at night and
Maybe in her Paranoia and lack of sleep
She just doesn't know how to handle the monsters. .oh fuck I  forgot. The monstrous to keep her awake at night
How do you handle this? Because I remember as a kid I
Had nightmares all the time. I still do! I have nightmares
Pretty much. . every other night I have a nightmare
And uh..
It's gotten to the point where I've just gotten used to it so much
it doesn't really phase me, but as a kid I had nightmares all the time and they were vivid with vividly real like
Incredibly real every single night I would wake up from something scaring me in my dreams
And I mean not everything but every other yeah, you're I got a story to tell here
I'm trying to open my soul about my childhood. You're just shaking your head like "No, that's not normal. You're a weirdo"
I don't need you judging me. .
Where you at?
Same. he likes that side
Eughhhhhhhh. Shoopty!
Hey how's it goin'? Howyadoin?
Okay. Alright then.
Let me just rewind my Doodadder. Okay! Oh, yeah like
Very frequently, and I remember one more distinctly than any other. I was a pretty typical nightmare
I was being chased by someone with a chainsaw. I must have been like
Seven or eight at the time. Maybe nine, but I was being chased by someone with a chainsaw and uh. .
It was uh. . It was really freaky because for some reason I was running
But I could see his face very clearly like just this huge angry face just burned into my mind and then I woke up
but the terrifying- the terrifying thing was
I could still see that face. That face was literally burned into my eyes
when I looked in my doorway
Infront of my bed, at the foot of my bed, I saw his face
Nothing else not his body not the chainsaw just his face staring at me from the doorway. It was the most chilling experience.
I threw my head under the covers like, I-I hid. I thought I was gonna die I-I cowered in fear and again
I'm a child- when your a child you see something horrible like that. Just a figment of your own imagination come to terrorize you
You think that it's real and I did. And I remember that like I will remember that till the day I die because it was by far
The scariest nightmare I've ever had and then I have nightmares every night and what's even weirder
Is that my nightmares are sometimes recurring?
Like I will. . I'll have nightmares in the exact same place and when I'm in the dream
I will remember the nightmare but not the fact that it's a dream. Like- ohh
Hey, how's it going?
Hey, buddy
Shove it a shoe
shove it a shoe
god damn it
this is so hard
All right fine, one more time before the end of the night. Oh you love that side
Hey howzit going hey
Okay, cool. It's gone for now great. Good to know
all right, cool, so
Yeah
Even if its day, I'll have nightmares in the exact same places that I've been before multiple times
I can't even count how many times you because I barely remember the nightmares when I get out of it
but some just stand it so vividly in my mind like that one from my childhood and
Yeah, it's just kind of my life.
Even before I started playing horror games. I mean that's why when I first started being a Youtuber
I was I honestly was very hesitant to play horror games just because
Like I was very scared. I just was yay, we did it!
We beat the first night and then you know, but in a way playing horror games kind of helped me conquer my fear
But they're still there
All the tiimmmmmmmmmme?
oh
Good
Hello, haha. Where are we now?
Yeah, hello. Dad
Mom oh, I can tell we're related cuz we have no eyes
I'll be over here playing with knives and such maybe some lasers staff area employees only oh
I'm not at home
Okay, then oh
Hello, Stacy is it I haven't seen the puppeteers puppet yet. I've heard that it's as big as a person!
Is it a mouse too is that what it is? Well? I see you over there. Don't think you can hide from me
Okay, then. Oh you are creepy. Hi, sweetie. Are you having fun? Hope you're happy with the place I picked out
It's just two of us while your brother is in camp. So you can decide what we should have for dinner tonight
Okay, I don't have to go. That's the boys restroom
okay
i Got a bad feeling about this
These arcade games are so boring
I want to ask the rat if we could get some new ones soon if any got a bit angry
The Rat is a real jerk
Okay, whack-A-mole
jungle Pinball Astro pinball yeah
this could do- (*Mark meet thing that tried to kill you*)
Heya kid I'm the Rat nice to meet ya. Say, the show's about to start in a few minutes
Wanna play Hide and Seek? Oh yeah I do. Neato! You go hide and I'll stay here and count to 100
backstage employees only. okay
All right, I'm gonna play hide and seek with the Rat. That's good
Are you looking for a good hiding spot by hiding under the one of the tables?
These tables. Oh one of the... oh whoops. I went the long way around
whoopsie-Doopsie
I'm gonna go hide under one of the tables apparently hey, you guys got a good hiding spot
Go hide under these tables hide under the table sure okay, oh
OK... Haha, I found ya
alrighty then
Thank you. That's good game.
Don't know if there was a spot that I could have actually won that but maybe there was so anyway
That's the first night. I am, like the other five nights at Candy's games
I'm gonna do a full playthrough of it
And I'm actually very eager about this one because it does put a lot more
emphasis on the
Backstory and gives the world some Fleshed out nature because that's a lot of things that these five nights at Freddy's fangame, Miss
With giving themselves a universe and they kind of did it you know and a half ass. Oh, that's in the title
It's just what it is way, but this is creating something and I like it
And it's good, so I'll be eager to play more of it. So thank you everybody so much for watching
emil Naco
Congratulations to the great game
So I'll put a link as well for everybody out there to play it too, thanks again and as always I'll see you
In the next video bye. Bub- bye!